meeting our last one of 2021
fire alarm procedures if the fire alarm
is activated vacate the offices via the
stairs please do not use the lifts
assemble in hawley square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber
please switch off or
switch off or turn to silent your mobile
phones and do not make or receive calls
while the meeting is in progress
please note the meeting is being live
stream for members of the public the
meeting will also be recorded and will
be subsequently broadcasted on the
internet
does anyone intend to film the meeting
item h the following members have asked
to speak under council procedure rule
20.1 item 4 councillor whitehead item 5
councillors austin smith and whitehead
item six
councillors garner austin alban and
whitehead
item seven councillors austin and garner
item eight councillors austin and
whitehead are there any other members
requesting to speak
apologies for absence
we have apologies from councillor cup
who is unwell after his kovid jab
but at least he's had it
item two declarations of interest does
anyone have any interest to declare in
the items of business on the agenda this
evening
item three
to approve this summary of
recommendations and decisions of the
cabinet meeting held on the 18th of
november 2021
a copy is attached to the agenda pack i
propose we approve we approve the
meetings do i have a seconder
councillor david saunders
do members agree
item 4
tls kpis quarter one and quarter two
housing performance report to introduce
councillor jill bayford
thank you leader
the reports show that the team has made
tangible improvements to the service
since transition from east kent housing
they celebrate where they have done well
for example receiving an outcome of
reasonable assurance in a recent audit
for landlord compliance
the improvements have been made in
income management and how they have
turned the capital program around
the reports also show where performance
is not where we want it to be
and give actions as to how to make
improvements in these areas
for example applying focus to landlord
compliance to complete fire risk
assessment actions and electrical safety
certificates so that they're in a
position to request the regulator for
social housing to remove the notice on
the council
void performance is being improved by
creating a dedicated team for the area
through a recent restructure
the team are making progress on our
ambitious improvement plan from which
sorry which will also make an impact on
the team's performance over the coming
year
thank you
that's it
do you recommend
i reckon i recommend that the cabinet
adopts these
two procedures
yeah sorry to note no no sorry
to speak under
20.1 councillor whitehead
thank you very much leader
um a very brief one from me um
in relation to the mirrors contracts
we are aiming for a 10-day turnaround on
non-urgent repairs but our june figures
show that mirrors are completing works
in an average of 34.78 days
i understand that this is linked to many
pressures including the availability of
materials but is there anything that you
think that we can do or are doing
directly to reduce these figures
i'd also like to say how pleasing it is
to see that we've acted directly on the
need for post-work inspections and
significantly raise that percentage
this has been an extraordinarily
difficult period and considering the
scale of the work involved at the
beginning of this process i think all
in-housing should be incredibly proud of
the way they have worked and continued
to work together as a perfect example of
this i would like to say what a
privilege it is to be part of tenant and
leaseholder group and to have seen how
that has developed and changed over the
transitional period
i'm sure that councillor jill bayford
will agree with me how positive this
morning's meeting was and how important
it is that the communication and
building of positive and growing working
relationships is still continuing and
becoming stronger
housing have worked incredibly hard to
create the in-house service and i'm so
glad that the foundations that we are
building are this solid
thank you
thank you
councillor whitehead for those some
good words i think we all agree with
that
um
so it has been um noted
uh
and seconded do members agree
sorry helen
sorry there was an element in there
sorry
sorry jill
thank you leader and thank you
councillor whitehead for
um your comments and question
i i yes i i agree the um tls meeting
this morning was very very positive and
it's a pleasure to see such improvements
that have taken place and the um the
bond between um
council and tenancy is improving as we
go
yes um
as you point out there have been many
many pressures
on mirs um to complete uh the turnaround
within the time suggested um i wonder if
if supporter can suggest
how how we think this is on this is
going forward do you think there's a
chance that it will be good thank you
thank thank you councillor whitehead for
the question
um and um
and i think all of us um think that we
need to see improvements in the response
times for that part of the service
um we have been working closely with
mirs to
improve our contract management
arrangements and liaison with
mia's contract team
and very specifically we asked mias to
consider appointing a thanet specific
contract manager concentrating on just
our work
and previously their contract management
structure covered the whole of east kent
um
which really was a kind of hangover from
the days of east kent housing
and i'm really pleased to say that
they've agreed to that and we have um
our own dedicated contract manager at me
is now
um we've um the team we've got regular
liaison with them and we also have uh
regular um uh
strategic level meetings uh with the
mirrors management team uh with our
management team and with uh
representatives of the tenant and
leaseholder body uh and those meetings
you know focus on the need for mirrors
to improve in performance in these areas
personally i'm optimistic that they will
do that
and
they they have they have had a
significant backlog of
non-urgent works that they've had to
work through
to catch up which has impacted on time
scales but you know for the future i'm
optimistic that they will improve their
performance around around these jobs
thank you very much councillor bayford
and mr porter
cabinet we've been asked to agree the
recommendations do we agree
agree
item five is the revision to the local
plan development scheme
local plan works program
every local planning authority has to
prepare and maintain a works program for
its local planned related work known as
the local plan scheme lds this is a
requirement under the planning and
compulsory purchase act 2004.
the current lds was agreed by cabinet on
the 17th of december 2020 following the
review of the adopted plan
since then work towards the local plan
update has proceeded with a cabinet
advisory group including members from
all political groups sitting to discuss
key matters for the update
however there have been some delays to
the work programme set out in the report
and it is important that the lds is
updated to reflect the new program
the report also considers other elements
of local planning policy and whether
they need to be updated the proposed
amendments to the local development
scheme are set out in the report i move
the recommendation
do i have a seconder
councillor bob bayford
speaking under 20.1 he's councillor
austin
thank you leader um i wanted to ask uh
three questions but first of all i
wanted to uh
welcome
the renewed commitment to finding a
permanent traveller site
as somebody who's been working with the
group of travelers who we located on
ramsgate port
i know that this is an urgent matter and
something that they as much as we want
to see resolved and i'm pleased to note
in the local local government
association first magazine uh this month
uh
announcement about a new um
guide to for local authorities to
providing and managing sites for gypsies
and travelers which i recommend to the
council um it points out that costs can
run into hundreds of thousands of pounds
for a local authority in a given year
when there are problems but also that
delivering good housing for gypsy roma
and traveller communities is a moral
imperative in addressing significant
health and inequality gaps
which have widened further during the
pandemic
my three questions are about um
whether we have discretion to require
that
developers
provide
good quality insulation in the housing
that they are applying to
build
following our commitment uh under the
climate provisions
secondly
whether we can look at revising housing
numbers given uh the
fact that the population is not growing
as fast as expected as a school governor
i've been involved in discussions around
that
and thirdly whether there is anything we
can do
under our housing provisions to
prioritize housing for people on our own
housing list when developers come
forward with proposals thank you
thank you council austin um
i'm looking to
bob porter with the um
with the first one the
regarding the um developers with the
insulation
uh yeah thank you for the question um
well the answer um to that when we can
include policies within the local plan
about our expectations about design
standards um we do need to be mindful
about national guidance on um on design
standards and obviously energy
efficiency is an emerging area in terms
of national guidance but you know that
there is scope within local plan review
to include specific policies of our own
about our expectations
obviously anything that we include in
the plan is subject to review in terms
of viability so you know if if we um
have policies that
significantly increase the cost of
provision then that obviously impacts on
the ability of
the planning system to
secure contributions for other things
that we might think are important so
in the end it's a balance of what we
think are the priorities for the area
okay thank you
and
question two um revising the housing
numbers as you know um we are constantly
looking for
ways um
to interpret the um requirements um
there are
it's quite a moving feast
going on at government regarding the
various uh
calculations and um especially on the
subject of brownfield sites but um i'm
sure bob can uh
probably advise more on the
on the actual record the statutory
requirements required by
central government on how we arrive at
our numbers but we are constantly
looking to try and find solutions to
not build
everything on the grade one agricultural
land but um if you can add something to
that well
um well the the obviously the formulas
for calculating housing numbers are
quite complex and
i'm more than happy to uh you know
another time go through that and share
that with you and talk about it in
detail
but you know in in principle the formula
for calculating housing requirement is
set nationally um
the the figures going into that are
based on our own local
research about population growth and
inward and outward migration
those figures go into that national
formula then then sets the requirement
for our local
plan in terms of housing delivery
um
i mean
clearly the the important point here is
you know what happens if we have a plan
that doesn't meet that requirement
and i think the answer to that really is
that it wouldn't or is unlikely to get
through public examination uh if we if
we put forward a proposal that didn't
meet the requirements that were set out
in national planning policy guidance
yes i think that is something that we've
we've made
clear
on ongoing is that if we don't meet our
housing
need then we will be penalized by
allowing developers to come in and
take over the whole process
so
i think it's obviously imperative we get
there and of course the
something coming to mind regarding
delivering um
a local plan is that very well aware
that the um gypsy and travellers site
must be included in that for us to pass
that examination so um that is high on
our list especially in the cag
the cabinet working group so
and and i think the third question was
to prior prioritize um locals for for
the list obviously if we are in control
of the housing ie is social housing
which is very much on our agenda then we
can prioritize
local families and the needs for the
local residents of fanec so
what we must obviously look at
the social housing and the affordable
housing which can be
somewhat governed by us if we actually
own
or part of an ownership in the actual
build scheme so um that would be
obviously uh one of the top priorities
in there as well so very keen to bring
forward a social housing plan
great thank you very much
so
also speaking um under 20.1 is
councillor smith
thank you leader
this is the first time i've addressed
cabinet so forgive me for any
inappropriate um
slips of the tongue there is
a growing clamor
from residents across the thanic
villages
as
large housing developments are gobbling
up
the beautiful the beloved and the
irreplaceable
farmland
that surrounds it
sane is not ready
for this gargantuan
building program
our infrastructure is inadequate
our natural environment is imperiled and
our residents are appalled
and
i will get to the questions
um in servicing
existing demand
southern water regularly discharges raw
sewage
into the sea that that's not acceptable
southern water is a statutory council t
on each proposal each development
age planning application
but has yet to admit this in capacity
um despite
their complaints about uh victorian
sewers
um
sorry councillor smith um yeah
we need to it's about the the the local
plan i mean obviously southern water i
can i can brief you on the southern
water and there is some some background
to that um outside of the cabinet
meeting but it must be relevant to the
actual item on the agenda which is about
the the local player
oh thank you thank you leader um
my question is really that should we not
and
will you not consider halting all
approvals until such time as southern
water is able to demonstrate a plan to
upgrade its infrastructure
um in order to meet the needs of our
existing residents for
and and
without taking into consideration the
additional demand
okay and my my second concern
is that um tdc just doesn't have the
enforcement capacity required to handle
this program
and we have an enforcement team of two
which are who are effectively pitted
against 17 to 21 000
and and
we don't have the right
to stake our residents well-being
on those odds
um it also seems that there are not
enough good site managers available
again i'm sorry cancer smith um
that that's a completely
sort of separate entity to the actual
enforcement that that occurs after the
building i mean that that is a local
requirement this is actually just
referring to the local plan
development so we must sort of stick to
the there are items that can be taken um
aside and discussed as as on other
another
nights but uh for this particular item
we must stick to the to the item which
is to um agree the
revised local plan work program so
these are issues that are not
directly relevant to the item on the
agenda so but quite happy to have
discussions with you
outside of the meeting offline so that
we can cover the areas of your concern
i do appreciate that point but what i
was
um driving at and perhaps i didn't drive
quickly enough
was that the local plan must include a
plan
to increase enforcement capacity in
order to accommodate
this level of accommodation
um
so
what i was asking was
is it not possible to consider
a moratorium on
approving any
further large developments until such
time as the shortfalls have been
addressed
that that's
well the short answer is no i'm afraid
um the um
the building requirement the numbers are
set by central government
um
we have to ensure as a local
authority to to meet the requirement and
as
mr porter said earlier if we don't meet
that and we fail to produce a sound
local plan then we will be at the mercy
of developers but
the regarding southern water that's an
item um that
isn't relevant to this particular
conversation but i'm more than happy
being part of the i'm now on the
southern water task force
um so which meets for the first time on
monday morning at eight o'clock so i'm
more than happy to brief
members on that on the outcome of that
which is to actually look at the
the issues regarding southern water and
the infrastructure but the new builds
aren't the issue with the southern water
problem what the problem is is the
victorian infrastructure that we're
trying to cope with so new builds
actually aren't the issue
just to put that that point straight and
as for the enforcement i mean that that
is an issue that that needs to be
addressed at the time when the builds
happen and come about but i'm sure that
there will be sufficient planning
involved with that so
it it's not on not your points but not
relevant to this particular item on the
agenda okay
oh
i think mr porter will come in as well
and add some
some knowledge to to the answer
thank you leader well two comments
really the first one is that um in
planning applications we would consult
with southern water about the proposals
for development and um the the working
principle is effectively that those new
developments should manage their own
drainage needs in a sustainable way
um and you know our preference always
would be
for surface rainwater
to for arrangements for that to be
managed on site and soaked back into the
ground
replenish the groundwater supply so
not add to
the pressures on the drainage system
the second point really is that this
report very much is about the timetable
for the review of the local plan
and is recommending extending that
timetable
and of course during that extended time
we will be working with southern water
about the drainage issues to try and
find solutions
um and you know incorporate them where
wherever we can so
the recommendation before cabinet
tonight is about extending the timetable
um so that you know those those sorts of
complex issues have got more time to be
considered
thank you mr walter um
speaking also under 20.1 councillor
whitehead
thank you very much leader um in
relation to the revised lds i note and
welcome the reports comments relating to
policy ho20 that location of suitable
gypsy and traveler sites is ongoing but
considering current needs and the
long-standing difficulties in locating
private land do we have any further
updates in relation to identification of
suitable public land to support our
future timetable
thank you
thank you helen we were discussing this
the other day
at
our cag meeting
we are pursuing
um
the search for sites unfortunately on
the first call for sites there was no
return but we are going to return again
to it
to hopefully
have
some sites come forward
we also can re examining our own land
and asking kcc to also consider whether
or not there is some suitable land that
they could put forward i don't know if
um
bob you would bob ported like to add
anything to that
well uh thank you i think the only thing
i'd add is that um the current adopted
local plan
includes policies about how the council
would consider applications
uh for egyptian traveler sites
so there isn't any reason why
applications um
for specific developments couldn't come
forward
in advance of the adoption of a new
local plan so that so there is already
an adopted policy about how we would
deal with any applications
thank you very much leader and mr porter
so i believe that is the end of 20.1
speakers so
um
i've asked members to agree um we've got
a second pose and second uh do members
agree
so item six
increase provision of housing response
officers at the tower blocks to
introduce councillor jill bayford
thank you leader
the condition of the council's estates
causes much this is dissatisfaction from
our residents
this has been made known to us through
direct complaints
surveys conducted and the our tower
blocking inspections which recently
taken place
complaints include the presence of
litter fly tipping and weeds and the
cleanliness of communal areas
the residents have also told us they
want to see a greater presence of tdc
officers on their estates
housing response officers are our people
that work out on our estates providing
essential services such as turning
paladin bins in bin stores unblocking
bin shoots removing rubbish and fly
tipping and clean cleaning and litter
editing
the council does not currently have
enough housing response officers to
provide a service that makes visual
improvements
to the condition of our estates
and therefore the report recommends an
increase in the budget to support
housing response officers and to provide
two additional offices dedicated to the
tower blocks
to fund this report
the report also recommends a new service
charge to the residents of the tower
blocks to pay for the enhanced services
these offices would provide
the residents of the tow blocks have
been consulted on this charge and the
results show a good level of support for
the proposal proposals as set out in the
report
the new dedicated officers will also
bring additional benefits to the tower
blocks such as adding extra security to
these estates where the nature of
high-rise living does often mean more
incidents of anti-social behavior due to
the number of people living in a smaller
space
the housing response officers will
become a familiar face to our tenants
and leaseholders at tower blocks making
residents feel safer and being someone
to report issues to as well as making a
noticeable difference to the conditions
of the estates
i move the recommendations set out in
the report
thank you do you have a seconder
councillor bob bayford
speaking under 20.1 councillor austin
thank you leader i just wanted to
welcome this strongly um from the point
of view of residents i've worked with in
the tower blocks who who
very much welcomed this and just wanted
to check that the responsibilities of
these officers will extend sort of into
the surroundings of the blocks and not
just internal
matters
physically internal matters to the
blocks that's all thank you
thank you council austin um
do you mean the immediate immediate
surroundings yes yes that's that's
certainly the case thank you
thank you um also speaking under 20.1
councillor auburn
well i think uh thank you chair um
i have a few things to say to say on
this um
i welcome
the fact that the council wants to
introduce to
further
members of staff
to be engaged within within the tower
blocks
however
uh i i would just take issue uh on one
of the things that uh councillor baef
has just just said
uh in relation to the um
relation to the consultation
um
i find out of 455 residents
only 76 replied
and out of those 76
uh that's the 46 percent of that said
that they that they agreed to
an extra charge
um
yeah i understand i've read the report
of obviously
um i have concerns that we are
asking our residents to pay
for two extra members of staff
this should come out of the housing rev
revenue account and i've registered
there's no there's no money in there
but there is money in there and we
should be paying you know tdc should be
providing the staff not asking our
residents to pay for our staff they
should we should be providing the staff
and
i hope
that and
that
the payment for these
two two members of staff
will be looked at if if you're minded to
approve this this evening that that you
will take into account that we should re
review this on a yearly basis
certainly for um
next year in relation to the to to the
budget out of the housing revenue
account
to ensure that these two members of
staff can be paid for
because basically what we're doing and
the report is saying
that a large number of the residents who
are on benefits unit universal credit
etc
um
oh that's okay they'll because they'll
they'll they'll be getting this money
through their benefit payment
so the taxpayers paying for it so the
government are paying for us to employ
two extra members of staff
and i just find i just find this whole
thing ridiculous
um
so i'm just wanna i know you're gonna
approve it but i just want to ensure
that that we will re
review this and hopefully put the money
into
into the revenue account to ensure that
our members of staff are paid for
by our budget and not by the not by
the residents of themselves
and um
again i will just go back to the um
to the
consultation
and remind you again 76 out of out of
455
and 46 of them agreed to this
you can't assume that all of the others
are happy with it
certainly for me i was speaking as a
wall counselor not as a cabinet member
but as a wall councillor with three
tower blocks in in my world where i meet
with them once a month and i'm being
told by the residents that they don't
want to pay this they haven't responded
but they don't want to pay it they don't
think that they should pay it
and also can i just i just add as far as
will casuals that we should all be doing
this you know we've provided our
residents as wall councillors with
litter pickers to go out and do and pick
their own litter up and also to try and
take care of of the
of of the planted areas and to ensure
that they're kept clean so um
well
whilst i support this double-edged sword
of of having the two members of staff
which is the best thing
i am totally against our residents have
having to pay it but thank you chair
thank you councillor auburn for the for
your comments um
these are it should be noted that these
are extra housing response offices
that have been
bringing them about
is as a result of
requests by our residents about the
areas of
of care that they are not happy with
so
um
i think all we could do is is
make the um consultation open to them
the fact that such a few such so so few
people responded was a disappointment
but
there was a majority it was also found
that those that
either
didn't approve or
didn't know
were unaware of the what the house and
response officers did
so um those that the ones that that did
support it
seemed very very sure of what the
housing
resorts officers did so
i really don't know what more we could
have done
in fairness and i feel that as these are
extra response officers that are there
to
um
to help out in a way that residents have
requested i feel it's very fair perhaps
you'd like to add to that
yeah thank you councillor bashford
i think two points for me the first one
is um
what we're proposing is dedicated
resources for for these buildings
um
service charges in themselves are not
something new we've got surface charges
for a whole range of different things
that apply to different blocks
across our housing stock
things that funded from core rent are
paid for by our whole tenant body
and you know if they're paid for by the
whole tenant body they should
effectively be equally provided to our
whole tenant body where we have services
that are for specific blocks they're
often funded by service charges to the
residents living in that specific block
the second point i'd make of course is
that these blocks include leaseholders
and having a service charge
includes that includes provision for the
leaseholders to make a
proportionate contribution towards the
cost as well
do you wish to you okay you're okay
so speaking again under 20.1 is uh
councillor whitehead
thank you leader
the role of housing response officers is
vital both in terms of building
community and in helping to provide a
prompt and aware service for residents
unless you are familiar with an area and
its needs it is very difficult to act
effectively
as such i have been in support of
localized officers and specific support
for the tower blocks for a long time
support for these roles has been very
significant among the tenant and
leaseholder group and they were equally
vocal regarding the support this morning
see and know what is needed in their
areas and know just how much hros can
contribute
i may wish wholeheartedly that the
budget were available long term to cover
these roles internally
but i think we also need to recognise
the level of support and intervention
required and the realities of the levels
of central funding of housing
in support of the tenant and leaseholder
group i would like to say that these
roles are important to them and welcomed
thank you
yes just thank you councillor whitehead
for your comments
thank you councillor bayfit
so cabinet we've been asked to approve
the introduction of additional services
and to recommend the cat to full council
that the necessary budget is approved
for this service do members agree
item seven community parks grant funding
proposed play error improvements to
introduce on behalf of councillor cup is
councillor pugh
thank you chair and uh i'll certainly do
my best everyone this isn't my portfolio
but i will certainly give it a crack um
this report proposes the expenditure of
211 000 pounds of grant funding for the
improvement of a number of play areas in
the district's parks on november the 9th
of november 9th 2021 the council was
notified of the grant allocation from
kcc for community parks as part of
contain outbreak management funding
the time scale for this project is short
and the funding must be spent by the
31st of march 2022
a project proposal has therefore been
prepared at pace and this report
proposes that the funding is allocated
to make improvements at four play areas
as follows there's zephyl zephylberg
present in cliftonville
which as
members will read from the report
attached to this agenda is the play area
is currently
degrading at quite a fast rate
we spend out of the 39 000 pounds a year
budget on maintaining our parks in the
last year we spent twelve thousand of
that just on this play area so it's
imperative that we do our best to
replace display equipment uh completely
and as soon as possible
with some of this funding as well there
is some funding that's left over so
we've also proposed to provide a freshen
up of the steel frames play equipment at
chris park
to paint it with i believe galvanized
paint
[Music]
to help with the appearance
at north down park as well in
cliftonville to provide a rubberized
safety uh surfacing around the play
equipment
and then an optional extra depending on
the budget and hoping that the budget
stays as it is and there's no increase
in material costs
we'd also like to replace the fencing at
the memorial ground
recreation ground in broad stairs with a
steel fencing rather than the wooden one
that has been there previously and has
been vandalized
therefore i would like to move this
report and recommend to cabinet that we
adopt and accept option two
tonight and i'm happy to take any
questions from attendees thank you
so the report has been moved uh
secondary
councillor david saunders
speaking under 20.1 councillor garner
thank you leader
um
obviously i'm pleased to see the
community grants
funding of 211 000 has been made
available for works to play areas in
planet
although
i have to say it's disappointing that
the government
gives us another recipient such a short
time scale to spend it or it seems lose
it this inevitably means that any time
for public consultation is reduced even
more than usual
the play areas identified especially the
viking ship playground in
cliftonville are certainly in need of
urgent attention
and you know i agree that they should be
the priority
uh residents in broad stairs
recently benefited from the renewal of
four playgrounds across the town there
which brought a new lease of life to the
parts they are situated in
and these upgrades are funded by section
106 money
which have been made available as a
result of new housing development in the
town i believe section 106 money has
been available
for play areas in cliftonville from
similar developments
there in the last couple of years
so has has any of this money already
been spent on playground improvements in
cliftonville
would it be possible to find out how
much
section 106 money for play areas has
been spent and how much is left to be
spent
if there is any of this money still
available then i would hope that it
could be used in conjunction with the
211 000 pounds
and this would then mean that the
provisional item that um you mentioned
of replacing the fence around the
memorial playground could be funded
because it will guarantee the funding
for that
along with any other with other
playground projects in other parts of
thanet that um aren't currently being
considered
thank you
councillor pugh i don't expect you have
the details on the section 106 but you
might have
all right okay
thank you leader ye of little faith in
me um
i will certainly do my best but i will
refer to um you know mike not councillor
humber unlucky for you if you were uh
council amber
mike humber i will refer to mike in a
second
for some of those details um i certainly
agree uh with council for ghana um it's
great to hear that there are four new
play areas in broad stairs in the
stranton area i mean that's wonderful um
interesting they've been funded by
section 106 agreements um
i'm sure mike will come back and has the
information if not we can get back to
you but you what you're proposing mike
is particularly in cliftonville if
there's been new developments and
section 106
funding from them is funding play areas
you know we've got a green party
councillor that's calling for a
moratorium on any development of any
kind across the borough across the
district
and then you're suggesting that it's a
good thing that we're getting section
106 agreements to build play areas so
you know i i can't
i can kind of see the irony there um a
bit of an oxymoron i'm sure but i'll
refer back to mike i'm sure he can um
provide the details on these sexual
honesty experiments in cliftonville
thank you councillor um
you're right uh councillor ghana that uh
and it is a very tight program so you
know there is
a very limited ability on um on
consultation and it's really a case of
you know where we where the need is the
greatest to try to you know to try to
deliver um you know a project as quickly
as possible so that we meet that funding
deadline so yeah that's the first one
you're absolutely right in terms of
section 106 monies for cliftonville i'll
have to come i'll have to come back on
that as you correctly said in broad
stairs last year we delivered some
you know parks on the basis of the
ellington scheme the section 106. um
next year we'll be delivering work at
boundary park in ramsgate with section
106 money um but for cliftonville i'll
have to i'll have to come back and uh
and confirm um
you know any section 106 funding uh
available for that i mean it's worth
saying that you know we have got over 30
parks play areas in parts of play areas
in thanaton and um very limited
maintenance budget so those sort of
um that sort of grant funding is is you
know very important to you know to
maintain and improve our parks
okay thank you and thank you for um
council of pugh's
i think he's ventured oxy bronic reply
so thank you very much
thank you i'd like to add that any money
from kent county council is gratefully
received in this district so and long
may continue continuing you spend it as
fast as you can uh councillor humber um
over to uh
20.1 uh speaking on 20.1 councillor
austin
thank you leader um
those who are new to or relatively new
to this still find it frustrating that
we can't come back when somebody says
something that we'd like to to
reply to so on behalf of councillor
smith i don't think that was what she
was suggesting
um
with regard to this uh item this is
extremely welcome very very pleased to
see um
good stuff happening for young people in
cliftonville which obviously is a
younger demographic than many other
areas um
if i can just point out that there are
as as uh mr humber has said many other
play areas in a really poor state of
repair across the the patch one i've
visited recently with councillor cup is
the one at the war recreation ground in
in newington and i'm wondering whether
cabinet in the light of the the limited
funds available
is considering at all the possibility of
any community asset transfers to local
community groups of play areas
specifically rather than whole
recreation grounds on the basis in
particular that
100 funding um can be
uh generated from certain external
bodies for example sport england for
certain of these sorts of facilities by
community groups if they are not if the
land is not owned by a local authority
but if the land is owned by a local
authority it massively restricts the
funding that can be applied for i'd be
really interested in whether
cabinet is considering that or will be
willing to consider that thank you
councillor pugh
thank you
chair um thank you council austin for
your question i think that's certainly
something that we could look into i
imagine uh particularly with my my asset
property hat on that it would be
quite hard from a liability perspective
to just transfer say a play area over
particularly the one that you're
referring to maybe the war wreck
or any play area if it's in a park
particularly if there's any accidents
and insurance and stuff like that i'm
sure mike can can add some more to that
but particularly if there's potential
for community groups to then access more
funding than if it was technically in
our ownership and i'm sure that's
something as the council would be
interested in looking into
but again i'm sure mike will know know
more about that
mike humber
thank you um
i i think the first thing to say is uh
you know our parks uh our play areas are
all in are all inspected in accordance
with roster standards so we've got a
team who um you know their their
full-time role is uh
obtaining maintaining those parks to
make sure that the you know the the play
equipment is safe um you know and
obviously
things like ethel burke present the
reason we're flagging that is because
we've got problems in maintaining it
that you know that's why we need to we
need to uh flag that up um
i mean
yeah as councillor pew has said it's
something that can be taken away about
transfer but parks have been transferred
one in westgate was transferred a few
years ago um to you know to the uh town
council so those
sort of arrangements can you know it can
be can be put in place um but
as i say you know
in terms of maintenance you know all our
parts are inspected yeah
okay thank you i do recognise that
thank you yeah i mean also
my views on
certain assets being transferred into
the community communities can come and
go
whereas councils be it district or
town and parish councils are obviously
there so i think it is more sustainable
if it stays within the local
government family as it were although
maybe it is harder to to access funding
but um it's probably um
a longer term prospect if it actually
remains within a within a town council
or within a parish council so um but
it's certainly as a councillor pugh said
something that we can look into
and if someone would like to bring it to
cabinet then obviously it can be looked
at
um also speaking
um
[Music]
i think that's it isn't it we have we
don't have any more speakers on that one
so um camera been asked to approve
option two
um from the report do members agree
disagree
so the last item for the evening is um
item eight council motion on notice
referred to cabinet disabled parking
spaces to introduce councillor saunders
thank you leader
this agenda item fulfills a procedural
requirement
and refers to a motion to council that
was brought to the council meeting on
the 14th of october
the motion read this council commits to
an internal audit of the number of
disabled parking spaces available in
relation to the numbers of residents
requiring them and commits to contacting
and working with kent county council to
bring forward personalized permits so
that our application based disabled
parking bays can perform the role that
is intended
we had two items on the agenda of the
14th of october the motion and agenda
item a covered
this this this
item
and the
answer that we had at the time which
unfortunately
for those residents who are concerned
remains the same and the response was
the process for applying for on-street
disabled parking bays is controlled by
kcc
under
the normal
current license arrangement and
although we work with kcc uh we are
bound by um their dictate as it were
with regard to these bays now these are
individual personalized bays that
disabled
individuals can apply for
to have a disabled bay in front of their
own premises there is a charge it's 250
pounds
and the motion requested personalized
permits well of course
in effect
the disabled driver has a permit and
it's his blue badge
the reason it was brought to the council
was the fact that we do um as i think
we're all sure um we are blessed with
inconsiderate parkers who use uh the
whole of the road irrespective of the
markings that may well be there um
and
we are being asked to work
in conjunction with kcc to see if we can
improve the situation and i commit
to that
situation and hopefully we can improve
the situation but i can't
believe that
within the legislation as it exists that
we'll get to the situation where we can
have
named parking bays rather than
disabled bays that are available for any
blue badge holder irrespective of where
they are
so um we are asked to note the report
note the motion and to continue um
with joint transportation and our other
means to work with kcc to come up with a
more um
desirable solution to the situation we
currently have
so we're being asked to note
the report
so
councillor saunders has moved
do i have a secondary
councillor pugh
speaking under 20.1 council austin
thank you leader actually councillor
saunders has answered what i was going
to ask during his comments so
i thought you had telepathic powers
councillor saunders so i'm
impressed okay i know chapter and verse
on this subject and
other subjects to do with blue badge
parking all right let's see if you've uh
read councillor whitehead's mind as well
so councillor whitehead over to you
i think possibly not
[Laughter]
right thank you leader um thank you for
letting me explain why i brought this
motion
to give a context to the motion i
previously brought to council i will
briefly in as much as i can ever manage
briefly sum up why it was brought
it's unfortunately written incorrectly
in 1.1 so i hope that this explains it
further
the social model of disability as
opposed to the medical model of
disability argues that we are disabled
not by our medical and physical needs
but by our environment not adjusting to
those needs
in terms of our provision for disabled
parking we are currently not adjusting
the environment to the needs of our
residents
under kcc and tdc provision
blue badge holders can apply for a
parking spot based on their blue badge
status
but that parking spot can be used by
anyone with a blue batch
this means that those who are most in
need in terms of mobility and access
so much so that they have been formally
assessed as requiring close and direct
access to their vehicle by local
authorities
can and often do lose that facility as
the parking spot that is intended
specifically to make their lives easier
is not specifically allocated to them
making its purpose in relation to that
individual redundant
we not only need to recognize the
importance of disabled parking bays
performing their actual function
but also assess the number of street
base bays we have generally available in
relation to the numbers of our
population requiring them to ensure that
we have sufficient provision
other councils are already leading on
this
personalized bay permits are not a new
policy
hackney and tower hamlets and others
already offer personalized bay permits
to ensure that disabled invid
individuals with limited mobility can
always access their homes and vehicles
without worry
i asked this council to commit to an
internal audit of the number of disabled
parking spaces available on our roads in
relation to the number of residents
requiring them and to commit to
contacting and working with kcc to bring
forward a personalised permit scheme so
that our application-based disabled
parking bays can finally perform the
role that is intended
i am if i'm honest slightly disappointed
by the content of this report as it does
not seem to acknowledge the nature of
the motion and often reiterates the fact
that disabled parking is a kcc related
issue
but the motion in and of itself
acknowledges that and simply asks that
we as a district council support the
idea of personalised parking permits as
other councils have done to support our
residents many of whom are disabled as
we have a significant number of disabled
residents and a higher percentage than
many other councils
2.3 states that we receive few
complaints regarding the usage of
disabled parking bays by other blue
badge users
this seems to be an odd comment as all
users of the system know via application
that other blue badge holders can use
the allocated parking spot
there will be no point to complaining
because the system allows it so as
frequently receiving complaints
regarding something that everyone knows
is permitted would be unlikely
the point that i was making with this
motion is that the system as it stands
is not fit for purpose
if you are allocated at bay outside your
home specifically because your mobility
is limited
usage of that bay by another individual
renders the purpose of the bay redundant
as you cannot easily access your home
personalized parking permits solve this
issue
other councils have recognized this and
as a disabled counselor i would very
much like my council to be proactive in
recognizing the needs of disabled
residents and pushing this issue
forwards with kcc
i was contacted by disabled residents
regarding this issue and asked to bring
it to council
i did
i am now asking the same things of
cabinet
understanding the rationale behind kcc's
choice and not offering personalized
permits is useful in terms of
understanding how to change this
but i also want more from my council
our equalities commitments read as
follows
we are to advance equality of
opportunity between people who share a
protected characteristic and people who
do not share it and foster good
relations between people who share a
protected characteristic and people who
do not share it
this is our chance to do so
disabled residents and a disabled
counselor are stating specifically that
this system does not work in the way it
should do
and as a member of this council i'm
hoping very much that we choose to
uphold both of the above commitments and
ask kcc to do the same
thank
would you like to
respond please
yes
as i say we're already committed to work
within
the areas that we can with kcc i do
understand the situation
you will know from the meeting of the
14th of october that we currently have
164 of the bayers outside disabled
residents properties
and
up to 5
of
the
road street
if it's suitable can apply for one of
these bays
yes it's unfortunate and i understand
because i'm contacted as well that the
resident doesn't have
personalized and universal use of that
bay
i equally understand having spoken with
uh representatives from other councils
that we as i said right at the start we
do seem to be blessed um with a high
number of inconsiderate parkers um ask
anyone who lives anywhere near botany
bay and they'll tell you all about those
inconsiderate parkers who take no notice
whatsoever of the
markings that they're parking on or near
to and yes i would like to get to a
situation where
the resident as if you like to call it
that way ownership of that parking bay
and we will continue to work with kcc to
see if we can come up with solution um
but the information and the message
we're getting currently from kcc is that
the system works elsewhere within kent
and it's going to be very difficult for
fanuc district council to change their
mind but as you'll hear i can wax
lyrically on the subject so i do
understand the subject and we will
continue working in that vein thank
you thank you very much councillor
saunders and just to confirm does that
mean that you're putting forward 3.1 at
this point
i'm i'm going to just clarify that okay
situation thank you so um yes um
estella's just confirmed that um we are
asked this is for agreement
and the recommendation is that cabinet
are asked to agree the following
the council engages with kcc on options
available to accommodate all those who
need access to disabled parking bays so
that is the recommendation and that is
what has been
proposed and seconded and
we will
agree on that now cabinet we agree
agreed
okay
i believe that
covers the uh
yep thank you leader and thank you
estelle
okay members and officers and members of
the public
i'd like to take this opportunity to
wish you all a merry christmas on behalf
of the cabinet to all members and all
officers even those not present this
evening
take care and be safe and
see you all in the new year so a merry
christmas to everyone
the meeting is closed charles
you